I'm Eddie Brock I'm a reporter I found
something really bad I heard a voice
what do you want about me
you have no idea how much you're scaring
me right now
what the hell are you
we are fit
[Music]
what's going on everybody I hope you
enjoyed that brand new venom TV spot
trailer it's only 30 seconds and there's
only a couple new scenes but still
exciting nonetheless before we dive into
it if you'd like to enter the infinity
war blu-ray giveaway all you have to do
is be a subscriber like this video and
comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero
okay so let's dive into it so to start
off this trailer actually seems to focus
more on Eddie Brock than it does venom
and what I mean by that is this trailer
seems to focus on Eddie figuring out
what the symbiote is what it can do what
he can do with it and what it is and the
scenes show how he's discovering all of
that so it starts off kind of like the
other venom trailer start off he
introduces himself saying I am Eddie
Brock I'm a reporter and then he says I
found something bad this is interesting
because in other trailers we've heard
him say that he doesn't actually think
the symbiote is that bad so again this
trailer is sort of showing him
discovering all of these things for the
first time didn't we get the normal
scene that's in most of the trailers
with Eddie Brock in his room the bad
guys come in to get the symbiote from
him and it's sort of attacks on its own
freaking him out in the process this
seems to be the first time that he
actually sees the symbiote at least the
first time he actually sees it coming
out of himself and then there's this
part where he is kind of got a trapped
between his hands and he says what is
that so again this clearly is the first
time that he's seen the symbiote come
out of him and attack so it goes on and
you hear Eddie Brock say what do you
want from me again not really
understanding what is happening but the
interesting thing here is his voice it's
very stressed it's very different and it
doesn't show the actual scene but if you
had to ask me my guess would be is that
it's one of the first times that the
symbiote truly takes over his body
completely and in doing so he asks what
do you want from me me we then have an
wayne saying you have no idea how much
you're scaring me right now yeah no
kidding considering that an alien
life-form is taking over his body and
the rest we've all seen except for this
awesome part of venom running in the
street right here jumping
car-to-car big Venom smile on its face
tongue sticking out it's just awesome
judging from what we've seen in this
trailer and what we've seen from the
other trailers there's going to be a ton
of action in this movie
venom is now officially less than one
month away so let me know what you're
most excited about for the venom movie
coming out let me know your thoughts in
the comments below also don't forget to
Like subscribe and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero to enter the Avengers infinity
war blu-ray giveaway thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you